and this project we're going to create a
budget complication now this project is
going to be special because we're going
to be using classes instead of
constructor functions so now let's look
at what we're going to be creating in
this application well as you notice
we're gonna have a budget so whatever
money we have
then whatever expenses we are gonna
accumulate and what would be the ending
balance so let's say we have two forms
one is going to be 40 expenses and the
one that other one is going to be
further about it if I try to insert
let's say 5,000 and I'm gonna press
submit or calculate I'm gonna have a
budget and the balance because obviously
there's no expenses yet now if I would
want to change the budget and if I would
say you know what I'm actually getting 2
grand more so instead I'm just gonna say
that this is gonna be 7,000 you notice
how automatically my budget is updated
and so is my balance however if I'm
trying to insert the value that's gonna
be empty or negative I wonder so I'm
gonna have feedback and it's gonna be
complaining that it's not possible and
if you notice the zero hasn't been
passed to my budget or to my balance so
once we set the budget next is gonna be
the expense so what would be expense so
let's say start with a fixed car so I'm
just going to say that fix the car is
gonna be 200 bucks so now I have the
budget of 7 grand
still 7,000 then expense is gonna be 200
and the balance is gonna be shown off
6,800 because we're gonna take into
account of expenses of 200 now there's a
couple of things that we can do first if
we would want we can get rid of expense
we can say you know what I don't need to
fix the car it was a mistake the
mechanic called and everything is fine
so I remove and again my balance is
gonna be 2a 7,000 because I removed my
$200 expense but let's say that we have
another rent so another expense and this
would be a 2,000 so again we're adding
the expense and you know just to show
you that then everything is working fine
we can have two of them and next month
came along and we need to fix the car
for 8,000 marks so again we are
calculating whatever our expenses
so in our case this is gonna be three
thousand now our balance is only gonna
be four thousand because we have
spending three thousand dollars and you
know what our landlord showed up and he
said you know what buddy
the rent is not gonna be two thousand is
actually gonna be three thousand so now
I can click Edit and I can say painfully
did instead of three thousand I'm paying
three thousand I'm sorry
instead of two thousand and paying three
thousand so I'm adding my expense and
now my balance is even less because now
my rent went up and I was able to edit
it and now these are all my expenses and
also another bad news came in my boss
came in and he said you know what you're
dreaming should getting seven grand
instead of your let's say getting a two
thousand five hundred he says I don't
know what you were smoking but there's
no way you're making that much money so
I'm gonna press calculate and now my
balance is actually negative so now I
need to reach for credit cards or
something because my budget is a low of
two thousand five hundred or my expenses
are way more now obviously we can add as
many expenses as we want and we can set
our budget our high or low we would want
and depending on that either our balance
is gonna be negative which is in this
case or if our boss says you know what
actually we had a huge investor and now
her salary went up again so now we have
a balance of six thousand so like I said
before we're going to be using classes
instead of constructor functions so
that's gonna be really really
interesting and like I said yeah enough
of me talking and let's start working on
a project the project setup files are
located on my github so you can either
go directly and just find by the
project's name or you can follow the
link that I have left in the description
of the video
now hopefully you downloaded a set up
folder and you are as eager as I am
working on this project so whenever we
have a download folder or setup folder
available we can just open it up and we
can notice what we have regarding the
HTML and CSS now there's not gonna be
any functionality so doesn't matter what
I'm pressing you notice that I'm just
gonna be submitting the empty
and I can just add expense nothing is
happening and also there's no feedback
so I can click everything but nothing is
happening so now this is our job to add
JavaScript to this HTML and CSS so then
I have a working app so in this case we
can just maybe close it because we
really don't need it and let's open up
this folder in our favorite texture now
as always probably for the 45th time
you're already hearing me saying that my
favorite editor is gonna be Visual
Studio code however you can use whatever
editor you would want now I'm already
skipping a little bit ahead notice we
have the index.html where we're gonna
have the forms and we're gonna have our
list and we'll have two types of form
this time now in the main CSS this is
where all classes are and notice that we
were just selecting styles so I'm just
using a main styles and just applying
them as a classes and then we'll also
have the app J's now because this is a
bigger project you notice that there's
quite a few things that I are already
right away added to the app chairs now
let me go over this just to make some
clarifications well first things first
prior to this project we have been
setting up a constructor function that
was responsible for all or instances so
in this case if we would want to have a
constructor function for the UI we
created a constructor function and then
we added all the properties to a
prototype and if we had some other
constructor function and if you would
want to add some time of properties in
there we added in a parameter and then
we set it equal to this so this ID was
equal to ID and here we passed the ID
now like I said this project is gonna be
different because we were gonna make use
of the es6 and we have the class syntax
now the class syntax is with a class
keyword first so we need to have a class
keyword then we would need to have the
name of the class and then this would be
curly braces so now again we would use
a variable we're gonna set it equal to a
new UI you new UI class instance and
then we would be getting the instance of
this class whenever we have class we
also have an option of having a
constructor method that's gonna run
every time we're going to instantiate
the class and we have two options we can
either pass the parameters again let's
say that we would say ID so every time
we would be passing this ID and we would
say this ID so for every instance
obviously this ID would be different
we'll just set it equal to ID or in our
case we're going to be using this
constructor and we're gonna preset the
properties so I already know that I'm
gonna have property of this budget
feedback and I'm just gonna use a
document query selector and I'm just
gonna set a budget feedback or expense
feedback and this is what I skipped so I
skipped all these selections because by
now we for sure should have a good
handle of selecting something so I don't
think that we need to write this for
let's say twenty minutes because this
should make all sense to us and
obviously as I'm working we will going
to be switching back to HTML maybe just
to show you where exactly I'm getting
this
but we already should have a good handle
of this where we have the form so if I
have for my obviously have the ID of
budget form so this is the form that I'm
talking about then the budget input the
budget amount so the input would be the
input field the amount is what I'm
getting at so the budget amount would be
here and so forth and so on
now after that since we have the
construction constructor that we run
every time we instantiate the class this
is gonna be added to our instance and
basically what we're gonna do is we're
gonna set up a methods on this class and
we're going to use this instance and
we're going to run the methods and most
of our work we're gonna be doing in the
class in fact we were gonna be just
adding these methods to our event
listener function and then world's gonna
be calling this function once the Dom
loads so let's do that first because
later on only thing we're gonna be doing
is creating
methods and was going to be making use
of the fact that we have access to these
variables I'm sorry do this properly so
this budget feedback we can right away
grab it so we will going to be working
with a function and we're just gonna
grab this let's say variable or not
variable the property we're gonna grab
this property and we're gonna make use
of the property so like I said there's
gonna be two more things outside of this
class now the first one is gonna be the
function of event listeners event
listeners listen nurse and we would want
to run this function as the Dom content
loads so let's make that other thing
that I was talking about and we will
just say document hey add event listener
now we're gonna be listening for a Dom
content loaded and once this event fires
we're gonna have a callback function and
within this callback function we would
run we would want to run this event
listeners function so this is gonna be
very straightforward and once within
this event listeners we would need to
create a new instance of this UI class
and then like I said was gonna be
listening for a three events in this
event listener and everything else we're
going to be doing within the class
so first let's select three things in
the event listeners function because we
will still gonna make use of that
because we're gonna be listening for
those demands and let's make a new
instance of this UI class so first
things first let's get a budget form and
we're gonna set this into our variable
budget form and again we're gonna do
this by ID get document get element by
ID and we're gonna be listening or
looking for a budget form ID now the
budget form ID is the one with a green
border and also we would want the
expense form so this wouldn't be in this
form and here our slope we're just gonna
change this around a little bit this is
not gonna be budget form this is gonna
be expense form and the last one is
going to be
expense list we're gonna have a title
and the expense value so again let me
copy and paste this
this is gonna be expense whist so here
let me delete the form and also let me
delete the list so here this would be a
list so we're gonna have budget forum
expense form an expense list so these
are gonna be my three variables that I'm
gonna hold the elements that I'm getting
back from the Dom then let's create a
new instance of the UI class so instance
of UI class and if we would want to
create an instance we do the same thing
as we're doing with a constructor
function so const UI and this would be
new UI and like i said before if we
would be passing something in a
constructor since we're running this
constructor every time we instantiate
the class we would pass it over here
like I did an example with an ID so
obviously for each in every instance the
idea would be that these properties
would be different well since I only
have one instance and I just want these
properties that would hold these Dom
values on I can just place them in a
constructor without passing any
parameters so now sure enough I'm gonna
have access to all these properties and
more important and that is properties to
the methods that we're going to be
creating here in the event listeners and
just be careful though whenever you're
working with the function constructor
you can place it anywhere I mean I can
go hundred lines down and I can still
have a constructor function and because
it is a function this is gonna be
available to me anywhere in document but
since this is gonna be as a variable
then be careful because you need to make
sure that you declare it first and then
you're making use of it so if I'm gonna
use this if I'm gonna move this class
you are somewhere down over here you're
not gonna have access to it so just be
careful and then once we have the new
instance of UI like I said we would want
to add three event listeners one is
going to be for the budget form the
other one is going to be expensed form
and then
gonna have expense list so let's do a
budget budget forms submit submit and
then maybe let's just create this budget
form submit so budget form submit and
add eventlistener so we're gonna be
listening for a submit event and then
this is gonna be a callback function now
for now we're just gonna be passing the
event and we'll just gonna ignore
everything because we don't really care
we haven't created these methods yet so
only thing I want to do is just set up
the bones and so basically the structure
of my event listeners function and then
once we're going to have the methods
available then we can start passing them
because otherwise this is not gonna make
sense so this would be the expense form
and the third one is gonna be expense
expense list
how are the expense list we're not
listening for a submit we're actually
looking for a click so click because
we're going to be attaching these events
to expenses that we're adding whether
this is gonna be a deleting or editing
or something like this so this would be
not a budget form the second one this
would be an expense form and I'm
assuming that you already have watched
quite a few projects already with me or
done some quite a few projects with me
so since this is already last project on
a object so I'm assuming you have
watched quite a few of them so I'm gonna
be skipping few things ahead so this is
not like three hours long so then let's
do expense list so we're adding a click
event instead of submit so we'll have to
submit events and then we'll have one
click event now why I'm passing for the
first two the event object because we
know with the forum this is gonna be
automatically submitting and we would
want to prevent that so you would want
to prevent default so event prevent
default and we would run a we would want
to run this for method from the event
object and this way this is not gonna be
resubmitting every time because we're
preventing the default so we're done
with our structure so now I'm glad
that we can start working in our UI
class of creating the methods now the
first method and we're gonna be creating
is when we are submitting the form
I would want to make sure that the value
is not 0 or less than 0 and if
everything is fine I would want to show
the balance and I would also want to
show the budget amount so let's go ahead
and let's start working now within the
classes and es6 we can skip right now
any kind of function let's say
declarations so we can do only a comment
if you would want to submit budget
method and we can just write the name of
the method that we're going to be
creating so submit budget form so this
is gonna be the method that we're going
to be creating and that's all we have to
do so now we have the method and just to
show you that everything is working so
we have a submit budget form now let's
do console.log and hello from es6 since
now we're using here 6 and let's go to
budget form submit event and let's run
this we have the instance of UI and sure
enough we have what we have submit
budget form and the only thing we need
to do is just run this method so as you
can see a lot of things are the same
however this just makes a way more
cleaner code since we don't have to deal
with the prototypes we just have class
constructor that has all the properties
and now we can start creating the
methods so once we save it let's open up
the google developer tools because this
is where we're gonna be spending the
last norm sorry next 10 hours I'm
kidding
hopefully I'm kidding and here let's do
calculate since the only thing we have
to do is submit the form and we have
hello from a6 and as you notice nothing
is rushing because we prevented the
default behavior so so far so good now
this is great now we have the submit
budget form method then we can start
warden the first thing I would want to
get the value where I'm getting the
value is from the budget input
because this input of the form has the
idea of budget input and I already have
assigned it to this again properly now
again with the first one we're gonna go
back and we're going to look at
index.html later on I'm just gonna
assume that if you have issues then just
go back to index.html and you can find
it now you can press command F if you
want to find it faster so let's say I'm
looking for a budget input I can just
write budget budget and the name would
be input here so now let's say that we
have no values because probably I
misspelled it or something so we have
budget this would be the name and this
would be the input so a budget input and
yes or no because this was a class that
I was selecting I'm sorry yeah my
property was with a capital letter
because I cannot use dashes and then if
I'm looking for the ID then I need to
use the dashes so therefore if you're
confused about something that you're
getting on you can use the command F or
make sure that you're not typing like
this with my input but I was looking for
instead of type of dashes and everything
is gonna be fine so what you're getting
back from is this form group that is
within the budget form and then this
would be the input so basically this is
the money that we're adding so let's go
back to app Jess and first I would want
to get the value so Const value is gonna
be equal to this now since I have again
access to the property I'm using this
and now the name of this would be budget
input the one that I was trying to find
with my command F with a fine and here
let's just get a value so what I'm going
to be devour
now since we have done this quite a few
times I'm not gonna console.log it we
can just do right away value and we can
just check what the value is gonna be
empty or so here this would be the
owner/operator the value is gonna be
less than zero so let's do less than
zero now if this is the case then again
we have access to a feedback the
feedback is gonna be showing I believe
somewhere here I mean again I don't want
to go back to index.html because we can
spend whole day like this
so basically we have the feedback that I
have selected and I have access to this
feedback so let's do this budget
feedback
now let's again use the classlist now
with the classlist we have an option of
add or remove or I believe it was
contained now in this case we just want
to add show item because like with other
projects all we did is we created this
budget feedback I gave it in the main
CSS of budget feedback and expense
feedback display of none and now I would
want to add this show item so this would
be the show of block so this is all
we're doing we're just dynamically
adding this so let's do add show of
meinem and also let's add some text
inside here so let's say this budget
feedback again the same property then
let's add as an inner HTML and since
we're using the inner HTML we can pass
the HTML tags and for this we'll using
the template literals so backticks and
then we can just write that we would
want to pass the paragraph and the
paragraph would contain value cannot be
empty or negative so pretty standard
what we have been writing before so
negative then we can close the paragraph
and again we were able to do this
because we were using the inner HTML you
wouldn't be able to do this with the
text content because then it's gonna
well you would be able to do it but this
is gonna show the actual tags and this
is not what you would want to do so so
far so good
let's test it out what we have now as
I'm submitting the form I'm purposely
gonna put 0 and now my feedback is gonna
be shown so now we selected the feedback
and we added the class of Shore now
obviously again like the previous
project we would want to hide it after 3
seconds 4 seconds 10 seconds I mean I
would want to hide it now you could
leave it it's not a big deal but I just
always like to work with a bunch of
functions in the project just so you get
to know them and I would want to hide it
I mean long story short let's just hide
now how we're gonna hide this we're
gonna use again the set timeout and
we're gonna have a set
time oh now this is gonna be a function
now this function is gonna require a
whole back function and this would be
the coal-black function it'll pass again
and then the second parameter is gonna
be how long this in how long this
function is gonna run so again let's do
4000 seconds and now let's do a this now
we know that we have the access to a
budget feedback classlist so budget
budget feedback and let's do class list
and remove so here we added this class
to a feedback now we would want to
remove the class so the moment we're
gonna remove the class what's gonna
happen well we're gonna go back to the
default and what was the default default
was a display of none so let's remove
class and the class is gonna be the same
off shell volume and I want to let you
know right away if everything is
correctly this shouldn't work but let's
just test it out so once we run it now
once again I want to test with the zero
value so now I run it and interesting I
have the value cannot be empty and after
four seconds I have some kind of error
well I mean everything is correct
correct I don't know why I'm saying two
times correct but everything is correct
so we have this budget feedback class
list I mean we had the Naxos literally
one line up now what is the issue why we
kind of access this and again the same
thing like we had with a constructor
function we can make a great use of this
but we always need to be aware of it
what is actually pointing to so if you
have been watching the previous
tutorials or projects you know that
there is an issue where at this moment
this is pointing to a global window
object and it's looking for the method
on this I'm sorry for the property on
this global window object and it's
trying to add the class list and it's
saying that it's it cannot read this
property because there's no such thing
there's no property on this global
object because obviously the property is
on this UI so again we need to make sure
that as we're running this function
within this method
now within this method still this is
pointing back to the class everything is
correct however since we're running this
function within this method now this is
not pointing anymore back to a class
it's pointing to a global object so
again we need to do something with a
self or you can name this really
whatever you would want so basically
what you would do you would say Const
and again I'm gonna use self but you can
write whatever variable is one and I'm
gonna set this equal to this so now I'm
grabbing the value of this that is gonna
be pointing back to the class and just
to show you let's do a log and let's do
this
so in this case let me show you what is
this pointing to now let's also have a
look at what happens within this
function where this is pointing to just
so you don't think that I'm I don't know
making this stuff up and let's also
console.log this so if everything is
correct we should have this that's
pointing back to our class then we can
have this to the global object and then
self is again gonna be pointing back to
a class so let's check it out again an
empty value and sure enough we have few
things we have the UI so this would be
the UI
now the second one is gonna be what now
the second one is gonna be div over here
and then we have the third one that's
basically not going to make sense so we
have a div expense feedback alert and
then we're gonna have a on call type
error can't read properly off now so
obviously this wasn't working as we
expected even though we had the UI of
feedback now this wasn't pointing to a
correct way now obviously I kind of run
these actually because they I have run
this after I called already this budget
feedback so this is not gonna make sense
let me fix this this is why we cannot
see anything
my apologies because you notice the
error runs and so we're not able to see
this so let's do this one more time
let's calculate and let's see it's more
interesting what we have in
so long so we're gonna have a budget
feedback so I'm gonna have you I this
will be our first this then we're gonna
have the budget input and sure enough
after four seconds now we have the
window notice this is the window object
that I was talking about so this is why
we're trying to access it in we cannot
and next again we have the UI so like I
said we have the UI then we have the
window object and then we have the UI
and again I'm spending probably way more
time than I should but I find it really
really important whenever you're working
with a Java Script to understand what is
this because this is really helpful but
you need to know where it is pointing to
so anyway long story short we need to
change this so instead of this we're
just gonna use self so now we're
reassigning this so now in this case
everything is gonna be working fine and
in four seconds we're gonna remove it so
again let's go up let's say then this is
gonna be empty value now this is gonna
console.log this and over here you can
see that seffle I mean this is not what
I wanted I mean keep on making mistakes
but that's great
calculate again trying to add negative
value and in 4 seconds this is gonna be
gone because everything is working fine
now after we have removed the feedback
now there's two more things that I would
want to do first I would want to grab
the value that I'm placing in the forum
and add it to the budget and also I
would want to remove and make this value
empty because obviously I would wanna
later on maybe pass some on their value
so I don't want the value to stay there
and the third one is gonna be show
balance and this is we're all gonna be
doing a little bit of calculation so
we're gonna call another method that
we're gonna create in UI class and like
I said most of the work is gonna be in
UI class so I know that maybe this is
gonna be frustrating for somebody but we
I mean most of the work here is just
gonna be passing one or the other method
now here we have one method but then
we're gonna keep on adding other methods
from the same class within this submit
budget form method because again I find
it important to understand how we are
working with a keyword of this
so here let's do a first budget amount
and what is budget amount I'm selecting
budget amount get element by ID this
would be the amount over here so budget
amount then let's have it as a text
content and we're just gonna pass the
value so if there is some kind of value
I'm gonna pass it here it's as simple as
it gets if the value is gonna be 0 or
less than 0 then I would want to show
them or tell the person tell the user
that they need to fix something if the
value is there the rate we're just gonna
pass the value after that I also like I
said I would want to remove whatever I
have the in the input so for this we
have a budget input property now this is
also gonna have a value since we're
selecting the Dom element and this down
element has a property of value since
this is a form in it this is important
so the forms have the value and we're
gonna set it equal to zero and the last
one we're gonna call this and show
balance and again for now I'm not gonna
write anything in this function I'm just
gonna call the function and we're gonna
do what we did before what's gonna write
console.log now in this case I have this
and this is not inside some kind of
other function that we're running here
so everything is fine this keyword now
is gonna be again pointing back to a
class so now in this case I can use this
show balance this natural balance
because I know that I'm gonna be
creating another method now the method
is gonna be well surprise surprise show
balance so now I have access to it so
now again like I said we don't need to
use any kind of a function key word
screen we can just write show balance
and for now we're gonna do very simple
again console.log I'm going to do hey I
am really or I don't know why I'm doing
this we can just do a backticks so
template literals hey I'm getting a hold
of this keyword well I mean this
keyboard yeah this keyword
and once I said hopefully I don't make
like 10000 mistakes with this keyboard
otherwise this is gonna sound very cocky
and you know what let me just comment
out this now keep it for your reference
and always if you have any questions
about this one of the best ways is just
to console.log everything out so let's
add some value since we have tested
already quite a few times with zeros
calculate 4000 and now sure enough I'm
running the method so so far so good now
we need to create the method of show
balance right correct because the first
thing that we did was just call the
methods and now we need to write
something within this method okay first
things first
now we have the method of show balance
however like I said this method is gonna
be interesting because from this method
we're gonna call another method so we're
gonna have const and here we're gonna
write expense
now here basically all I'm trying to do
is calculate the expenses and I'm gonna
create a method that's gonna do this for
me so we're gonna have total total and
expense as you notice I'm not selecting
the properties that I had on my
constructor I'm not doing that I'm
actually selecting a method again with
this the same as here however again we
haven't created the method so here let's
do a this total expense or to be more
correct we can just do comment of total
expense and let's write it this is gonna
be total expense and this is gonna be
our method now again we can do a console
log just to check that everything's
working but I think that after a few
times of doing that this is becoming a
redundant so we know that we're gonna
have access to it and the way we're
gonna have access to it that we're gonna
add this to the value so basically this
method is gonna calculate everything
that we have in a list now obviously in
our list we have nothing right now so
right now we're gonna be working a
little bit in the dark so we're gonna be
writing a function that in maybe right
now it's not gonna make sense but the
moment we're gonna be starting adding
the values this is gonna make
way more sense than we think right now
and here the basic idea behind this
method is I would want to run through I
would want to calculate whatever items I
have over here and once I calculate the
items I would just want to return them
so let's do very simple let's do let and
we'll just gonna call this total again
and we're gonna be using this later on
and let's just set it I don't know to
400 something like this so we always
have this value let's do very simple
return off total now again like I said
later on once we're gonna have the
actual values we will gonna make this
functionality where this is gonna make
way more sense but for now I don't see
the point of going through if there is
no values really I mean it just kind of
it doesn't really make sense so let's
have this and now we know that this
expense should have 400 because we have
total expense and we're just returning
Dietl so good enough we have a
hard-coded value of 400 now next we're
gonna be working with a total so we're
gonna have const tomorrow no this is
gonna be the variable now here i would
want to parse int so I'm gonna use this
method that I have with parse integer
and the reason for that is because I
would want to grab the value that's
gonna be in the budget so whatever value
has been passed in the budget and I can
remember important thing I'm only
running this after I have added already
in the budget now this is another
stumbling point now we need to only call
this callback whenever already there's
some value otherwise this is not gonna
make sense you cannot get some value
back from the Dom element if there's
nothing there if you're just running
this function right away as the document
content loads so we need a parse integer
now here again we're gonna use the
properties we have and we'll have a
budget amount text content so only thing
I'm doing here here I'm passing the
value so here I'm saying this budget
amount text content value is equal to
this value and then I'm getting it back
so basically when this show balance I'm
getting it back
now we could have set it up that I'm
passing it as
a parameter or let's say your argument I
mean we could have done a lot of things
so I just chose to do it this way and
again don't judge me for this everybody
can do however they want so here let's
do an expense now what is an expense now
like I said later on like Spence is
gonna make sense because we're gonna be
calculating all the values for now all
we're doing is just returning to 400
since we're getting back this from the
method and now let's do a this balance
amount text content is gonna be the
total because as you notice I have the
expression where I have the budget
amount is gonna be subtracted from the
expense and now I just want to show it
so whatever value I have in the balance
so this balance amount again this is a
property that holds the Dom element with
a budget amount and let's do a text
content this is gonna be equal to total
so very simple we just grab the expense
that we're gonna calculate later but for
now we have 400 then we grab the budget
amount but since we're taking a text
input then when I'm sorry a text input
text content I want to run it through
the parse integer so I want to get the
integer and then I would want to get
whatever total I have and now since I
have the total I use this balance amount
text content and again this would be a
balanced amount so balanced amount over
here and I would just want to check if
this value is gonna be less than 0 then
we're going to show it with a class of
read so we're gonna add a red color and
then else if it's bigger than 0 then
we're gonna be green and then last one
here is gonna be if it's equal to 0 then
I'm moving a half a 0 so let's write if
and total so now we're looking for a
total if total is less than 0 so what we
should do so we have a dis balance and
classlist again we first can find a
class list and then we're gonna find
what do we have in the CSS so we're
gonna remove show of green because that
I want to continuously keep on adding
two classes so basic idea is since this
is going to be changing we can have more
expenses or we can have a bigger budget
they're smaller but
I don't want to keep on adding and
adding and adding classes so every time
I'm adding the class I want to make sure
that I'm removing the other classes that
I'm gonna be adding hopefully this makes
sense and here we have this balance and
again this is gonna be balance class
list and again instead of removing now
we would want to add read so whenever it
is below zero we would want to add a
color override but we would want to
remove the show green of show black if
it was there before because obviously we
made it this can always change now two
things the balance is again the easiest
thing is going to be finding balance
balance now where we have the balance
the balance is gonna be here so we have
the expenses this will be zero and then
we have a heading six of balance
then the balance icon and the actual
class of balance is gonna be where we
have the dollar sign so this is what's
gonna be turning red or green or
something like this so this is what we
have now after that in the main CSS
classes are very straightforward so red
is gonna be red green is gonna be green
so black I mean we can guess isn't gonna
be blue no it's gonna be black so let's
go back to app is and let's figure out
so we have if the total is less than
zero so now we have very easy task so we
can just grab this and we can just copy
in first time here we're gonna say else
if and if the total is bigger than zero
then we would want to do the opposite we
would want to remove show red and show
black and instead we would want to show
green and after that we have wonder
where this is gonna be equal to zero and
I don't know why but I looks like a
copied two times hopefully I don't know
I'm not just having some kind of an when
I say heart attack but some kind of
brain freeze or something where's no
show red show green so with the zero we
would want to add name black one shown
black
and we would want to remove what we
would want to remove shall read and show
green again whenever a class we're
adding the other twos we would want to
remove so this would be the show
balanced no like I said later on we're
gonna still work on a total expense so
this would be the case right now so
let's save it and let's figure out what
we have so for now there's not gonna be
an expenses so this should be all green
calculate and sure enough we have
everything green over now if I'm gonna
have the adding on expenses this if
everything is working correctly this
should be black and I mean we can just
check it out with a black one this
should be black with zero and this is
black so I think that everything is
gonna be working fine now as we have the
show of balance now everything is
working fine with a submitting of the
form now the next one is gonna be really
interesting because then we're going to
be working with an expenses and this is
gonna be well let's just put it this way
there's gonna be a little bit more code
than this so let's start in our event
listener since this was a submit budget
form and the next one won't be the
expense now for the expense form again
the method name is not going to be very
original submit and I'm not gonna say
budget I'm gonna say expense because
this is gonna be the most original
problem method name ever
now here I have the submit expense to
form and now we can save it and
obviously we need to go back and now
it's saying that there is a well no it's
actually saying that there's no lots no
slope and that's no slow Network and it
doesn't really matter to us or locally
but now we had what we had a submit
budget form now we need a submit of
expense form because this is gonna be
way more interesting so after a show
balance and we can just maybe leave this
total expense all the way in the bottom
we can do a submit submit sub
expense form so this is gonna be our
comment now within this method of submit
expense we were going to be selecting
few properties and we're gonna be
creating the variables so first is gonna
be const expensed how you know expense
value is gonna be very similar to what
we had in a budget now the difference is
this is not gonna be budget input it's
gonna be expensive but we have expense
input in an amount in one so whatever
the actual expenses and whatever the
amount for that expenses so this not
expense input and again I suggest if you
or have confusion where we're getting
this you can use the command find and
you can just find the class that we're
searching for Const amount value so
amount value and this is gonna be equal
to a input amount so amount input and
again we're gonna use value and again
since these are forms we can use this
property value to get back to value now
we really don't care what we're gonna
become so logging if you really want we
can console.log the amount value but
this should be straightforward what
we're getting back and again this is
gonna be very similar to what we had
before so we're gonna be checking for
three things this time so it's if
expense value isn't gonna be 0 so if
you're passing something that well
passing with no name then we're gonna
have or so in this case we're gonna say
amount value so amount value and in this
case we're gonna say this is equal to 0
and last one is gonna be if the amount
is less than 0 because these both of
them are type number so we can also put
0 but less than 0 but this wouldn't make
sense if we're trying to actually setup
our budget so again or operator and
amount value is gonna be equal to less
then 0 so if any of them are true since
we're using the or operator again we
would need to work with this feedback we
would need to add the feedback so this
in this case this is not gonna be budget
feedback this is
any expense for you back and again this
is set up in properties of our
constructor so let's go down and an
expense feedback let's do the same thing
we had before class list now again we're
gonna first show the item and then we're
gonna add some text in there so let's do
show item and again the setup was
exactly the same like we had with a
budget feedback where the initial was a
display of none and now we're just gonna
show the item so let's save this and
still it's gonna be complaining about
some slow Network and then we'll have
expense feed by a class list now after
that I would want to work with a
innerhtml so this expense feedback inner
HTML and then let's look at a template
let's roll since we can use the inner
inner HTML and we're doing the same
thing that we had before so we have
paragraph values cannot be empty or
negative so this is going to be passing
and then since we're using template
literals we can just write whatever tags
we would want over here and again since
we're doing the same thing as before we
need to reassign so have Const self and
this is gonna be equal to this because
we're gonna be calling the same thing
we're gonna have a set timeout function
and this okay I keep repeating this
function is going expect a callback
function now this callback function is
going to be run after specific amount of
time which is a second parameter again
in our case 4,000 milliseconds which is
4 seconds and since we already have
covered the self and expense feedback
again we're still accessing the class or
the instance of the class and we have a
class list and now in this case we would
want to remove so remove what we would
remove well it's simple enough we would
want to remove the show item so as we
save this everything should be more than
fine and we're gonna have where we can
just test it out
you know what let's do a first fix a car
and that expense and sure enough we have
a values can it be empty or negative
even though if only one of them
so you can already guess if both of them
are gonna be negative then we're gonna
have the same thing now after that let's
do you know what let's do just the
second one so let's say that or let's
try you know what let's try adding a
negative value so you'll fix a car and
still we have the values can it be empty
or negative so basically this is all
we're doing we're just checking for the
values now this was a first code block
for Eve so this was if now we need to
else because obviously there's gonna be
cases more hopefully most times there's
gonna be cases where all the values are
there so let's do another variable
this is gonna be ml now we are getting
back the amount value now on the amount
value we were getting back is against
string so we need to use again parse
integer so we need to convert it
otherwise this is not gonna make sense
so we're gonna have amount value and
we're using the parse integer so now
this variable is gonna hold whatever
amount we're passing in however this is
gonna be turned into number not like we
had before as a string so here let's say
this and this would be an expense value
now the expense input sorry not
expensive how you and we're just set it
setting again equal to a empty values so
if everything is fine we added an
expense I would just want to delete the
field so the leads the field should be
empty and again I have the access to the
properties because of a constructor and
then this would be expense out input
then I have the amount input so I have
expense input and amount input and they
were going to be cleared once everything
works fine then I also want to set up
first a object and we're going to create
an object and then we're going to pass
the object right here notice we have a
item list which is the array that we
have so I'm going to create a object
that's gonna contain the value of
expense and the amount expense and also
I'm gonna grab the ID and I'm gonna add
a 1 to ID and before that I'm just gonna
add it to a item list so we're going to
do a incrementation of ID
so first let's create an object of let
expense so this is gonna be our expense
and this is gonna be an object now ID is
gonna be equal to what well this dot
item ID now we're we're getting back the
ID I'm gonna scroll up this is gonna be
our item ID so this is where we're
getting daddy now second is gonna be
what this is gonna be title title is
gonna be equal to expense value so
expense value is gonna be here we have
access to it so expense value and here
we have the expense well now for the
amount I would want to grab the amount
not the amount value because remember
now this is a number so amount this is
gonna be equal to month and just a quick
note technically with es6 we could have
just skipped this if the both names are
the same we don't need to add property
name and the value if they both match we
can just skip it and just say amount
since we have the access for this amount
just that's just a side note and here
we'll do a this item ID like I said we
would wanna increment and this is gonna
make sure that each and every item we're
adding is gonna have a unique ID and
then we're gonna do the same thing as we
did in a previous project where we will
grab the array the item list array and
we'll just gonna add using the push
method and what we're gonna be adding
well the expense that we're creating so
whatever we have here this variable and
this object be more precise then we're
just gonna be adding now after that I
would want to do through two things I
would want to call two methods again
which we haven't created yet now the
first one is gonna be show I'm sorry add
expense I'm basically the display the
expense and then I would want to show
the balance so here we're going to call
this first the add expense and again we
have the access to it because we are
within the method still we're not within
some other function so this is gonna
point to whatever method we have and
this expense is going to expect a
parameter of an object so since we have
the object
beyond expensive object we're gonna be
passing it so we're passing in this as
an argument that we're going to be
expecting that in our parameter so let's
just make sure that we are outside the
previous method and let's maybe leave a
come and just don't forget we also have
a show balance I just don't want to
create it right now so we'll have a show
balance so once we create this we have a
add expense so let's make a comment add
expense and here again this is gonna be
a method that expects to have a object
so add expense and we can name this
whatever we want again this is a
parameter so let's just go with the same
one as we had with an expense but we can
name this really independently so again
we're gonna create a div and again why
we're creating this there however I'm
gonna go back to index.html I believe
this time I commented out notice we have
the title value first we have the
expense list this is this is where we
have all our expenses then this would be
the title and for the tile value and
expense tile and then we'll have a
single expense now each and every time
obviously we're gonna be adding this sim
single expense so only thing we can do
is we can just grab this div this is
gonna be my single expense because we're
gonna be doing a lot of things that we
did before we're gonna create a div
we're gonna have this class and then
we're gonna place everything within this
day so actually you know what I'm
selecting the wrong div because I only
need this guy because I'm gonna be
creating this parent if I only need
whatever is inside so I'm gonna let me
select this for a third time you're
probably sick of watching do this but
cons div then we're gonna do a document
and we're gonna create an element so
let's do create element we're gonna be
creating a div now we know that this div
is gonna have class of expense because I
just show you so we'll have class list
of add expense and just as a side note
you can really do however you would want
but I find it much more easier first
in HTML now obviously you cannot see it
because I commented out but in general
you make it in HTML then you apply the
classes and then at the end you can just
comment it out and add it with a
template literal and I think this is the
fastest and best way to do this now
again this is just my opinion I don't
I'm not saying that I'm right or wrong
I'm just saying what I prefer to do it
you really can do however you would want
and I just copy and paste this now I
have the expense ID and also here I have
the expense and now where I'm getting
the expense I am getting back from the
object so it's as simple as that
now I could have left these empty but
for now we already have done so many
projects a lot of things are making or
any sense where we're getting this from
I'm getting back the object and I just
want to have access to this ID and I'm
gonna add this to a attribute of data ID
to a edit icon and to a delete icon
so basically every time I'm gonna be
clicking icons I want to know the ID
because this is gonna help me to filter
out the list that we're creating and to
make sure that we're getting the proper
element and we're deleting the proper
element most importantly deleting I
guess well I think probably is also
important so we have the expense ID and
expense ID and we also need a title and
we need the name out so let's find out
where we have the amount so first this
would be a amount so again we are using
a template string so we can access the
variable with a dollar sign expense
title yeah and then no you know what
this was the amount I don't know I am
maybe having some kind of brain freeze
right now title right here good one good
going again we use it I don't know why
we had now I know what this was the
wrong dollar sign so this is fine oh you
know what no it wasn't sorry so I
apologize and just keep on seeing too
many dollars right now expense title
this is what we need so expense and this
was gonna be an object and
so once we say this now we obviously
need to use the again some kind of
method to upend this to something now
since we're working within our class the
method has access to one there's access
to this property now this property holds
the value the value is what the element
that we're getting back from the Eddie
let's scroll down let's look where is
our method then this would be this
expense and we will name this expense
list and we're gonna do the method of
guess what happened child and what we're
a pending well I mean we can spend half
an hour thinking about it but I would
probably say the div since we created in
there but I mean we can happen whatever
we want really but let's just do the div
I think it's gonna make a little bit
more sense so we have the budget
complete we have the expense complete
because we're done probably to fix
something so we have fixed car 400 that
spends boom fix car 400 great well
nothing's shown here well we haven't
done anything right so that's where
nothing is showing so fix car for
running awesome now we still have an
issue here why this is not empty we I
thought we were working on this we had
the expense input was supposed to be
empty now also we had the amount input
that was supposed to be empty so let's
figure out what is an issue why we don't
have the proper way of doing that the
reason that is because we need to select
a value so for now we're just targeting
the whole input see over here we have
the input now this is why it's important
whenever we were working with a forms we
need to use actually value this is kind
of crucial otherwise you can see what's
happening we cannot get the value it
would be getting the value where we
cannot set the value now in this case
we're setting the value so let's try
again let's try the fixing the car I
mean let's do this time 5,000 and sure
enough everything was fine we cleared it
and I want to say boom again
because we added an expense and I can
keep on adding as many expenses as we
would now like I said the second one
that we are interested is showing the
balance so again this would be the
method that were interested so we have a
show of bound now if you remember we
already had this one time show of
balance and remember the reason why we
did not want to run the expenses is or
add anything to the expenses that we
were creating is because there was no
values so I think now it's gonna make a
little bit more sense if first we're
going to add this show balance the
method that we already worked before and
again this method is what we used
clearly when we were working with a
budget so nothing has changed with this
method so we can have the same method so
this this show balance and now once we
run this method then something should
happen and that something is gonna be
first of all budget so five thousand
calculate then we're gonna have a forty
six hundred and again the reason for it
is forty six hundred because we run this
show balance and we have hard-coded the
values so every time I'm going to be
adding this fix a car nothing is should
be changing yeah you notice nothing is
changing even though I'm running it so
we need to go and fix this total form
otherwise this is not gonna make sense
we I mean total expense I'm sorry we
have total expense so we need to fix
this
so first let's set a amount equal to
zero because this is gonna be our
starting point then how we want to check
if the item list length so the item list
is the element that holds all the items
there's more than one item I want to
start calculating this if there is no
item I don't want to calculate anything
so here I'm gonna say like this I'm
gonna say if this and I have access to
the item list because it is in my
properties then I'm gonna calculate if
the length of the item list is bigger
than zero then I want to want to
something other than that I wouldn't
want to do anything other than that I'm
just gonna say very simple I'm gonna say
this and now I'm gonna use the expense
amount it is gonna be text content so
again we have the budget amount we have
the balance amount so this would be the
expense amount and one's gonna set it
equal to total so all I'm saying is if
there's no list item just an expense
list this should be zero there's no
reason for it to be anything other than
zero because we haven't added any
expenses and last thing I also would
want to return the total which would be
zero so this is all correct all we need
to add the logic where we have the item
list length is bigger than zero and what
we're gonna do over here well well it's
gonna be very simple we're gonna have a
total then we're gonna set it equal to
this that item list so we're gonna have
a item list now what we're selecting
this item list for we're gonna be
selecting so we can run the method of
reduce now why we're running the method
off reduce because we want to calculate
the values so this is all we're doing we
just would want to get the values that
we have over here so first things first
maybe in this case you know what let's
run the console log just so we can have
a better understanding of what's
happening
so let's first let's do a console log of
what we have in the item list and let's
add some items just so we can see what's
happening so we're gonna have item item
list over here and let's just
concentrate on this and let's do a I'm
gonna fix a car 300 adding once an item
list is actually not defined we have 0 1
9 well duh yeah obviously because we
need to use this I'm selecting this
again so let's do fix a car
300 expands so Norris empty array okay
so why I'm getting the item list the
reason for the item list is very simple
vadym list is our array so every time
we're adding something in the atom list
what do we have sorry I said
Dean's not empty we have one value sorry
I misspoke but there is every time we're
going to be running this and we're going
to be adding this to a item list
remember the item list not push now we
have access to it this is the whole
purpose of the creating array so what I
would want to do right now if the length
of this array is bigger than 0 I know
that there's some items the only thing
I'm doing is I'm just gonna use the
reduce function and I'm just gonna count
all the values for the amount property
because I know that I'm setting the all
my amounts to all the objects that I
have so let's do another one just again
I don't know buy milk something
redundant buy milk and what would be the
expense I don't know let's say note went
up the price in it's 200 bucks
two items two items perfect good amount
300 and 200 so again the idea is I'm not
gonna be looking this in a Dom I have
access this in the array so only thing
I'm doing is just getting my reduce
method then I can use and I'm going to
just count all these values together
that's all it is so let's do again total
now we're gonna set this total equal to
what we're gonna set this total equal to
reduce now unlike the Billy for H and
the filter in the map this is not gonna
it can return more than just or not more
than just not just an array it can run
using the reduce method we can return
whatever we want so in our case we just
want to return zero so the number I'm
sorry not the zero and we're gonna start
with zero just the number we want to
return the number so let's do a reduce
now reduce function and it kind of gonna
take a callback function and this
callback function is gonna take two
parameters now a lot of times they're
called accumulator and current now you
can really name them however you want
but again I'm just gonna use the
accumulator and Accord now we can also
set it maybe this one to total then this
would be a function block so the
callback function block and then for
reduce we need the initial value so this
is what I was saying with zero
so all I'm saying is I can write here
whatever i want i can write array I can
write object however what I'm looking
for is number because I'm setting this
total to number so each and every time
I'm gonna be adding these values I would
want to get the sum of it and display
whatever I'm getting back and also Kalpa
like my balance no how do I do this so
first of all whenever we're using the
with the reduce we need to return the
accumulator so what what needs to be
understood that every time we're running
this reduce we're gonna loop through
this array and think of this as a total
that it's gonna be returned each and
every iteration so we have access to
this accumulator and we're gonna
probably may be doing let's do some
console logs just so it gives us a
little bit better idea but here let's do
first a console log and let's do a
console log off accumulator so let's
call this I don't know a I mean this is
not totally correct but let's say just
total so row and let's do template
strings this is gonna be a little bit
easier so total is now we're gonna
access the accumulator so first let's
look at a converter and then let's say
and the current value is and now let's
do again access T value of current so
let's do a first of console.log then
let's do right away our one where logic
we would want and here all I'm saying is
that with each of iteration I want to
grab the value that I'm accumulating and
I just want the add the current amount
that I have now I'm getting the current
amount because I'm looping through this
array item list now the item list has
the atoms of objects correct so current
reflects the object now where I have the
value in the object I have the in amount
properly so this is why I'm gonna say
current so current object then
iterating through that I'm using in my
iteration and I would just want the ADI
amount and like I said last thing I
remember always return the amount
otherwise I'm sorry the accumulator
otherwise this is not gonna make sense
so let's save this and now we're gonna
run this every time we're gonna be
adding values so I'm sorry I'm gonna be
sticking with the fix in the car because
it's saved here I just saves me typing
add expense now I have the total is zero
and the current value is an object not
all this because I made a mistake I'm
not looking for a current I know that
this is gonna be an object
I need a amount this is what I need and
this is what I'm saying is as we're
going through this we're getting these
values as an object because we have
stored them in the item list as an
object so again let's do fixing the car
for the forty-fifth thousand times so
here we have total is zero so we start
with zero and the current value is 400
now what do you think here the amount
right now is because we added this 400
this should be 400 right so in the next
iteration we're going to start the total
should be 400 and the current value is
gonna be sembly so let's try this out
let's do another fixed car because we
really don't give a damn about it
whatever name it is and let's just add
hundred hundred add expense notice the
total is 400 calories 100 so this is
gonna be added again to any 400
iterations we're gonna have 500 so this
is how we're getting back to values I
mean the reduced function is extremely
extremely powerful I mean I mean this is
one of those things if you want to learn
something or energies because this is
gonna save you tons of time it's really
one of the in my opinion one of the most
definitely out of the all the array
methods the most powerful method let's
say this now we have the one of those
total expense done so now it kind of
made a little bit more sense as we were
adding the values and now we need to
figure out what we're doing so we have
everything set up so we have submit
expense form and we have the balance and
if I'm correct
everything is working correctly right so
we're gonna have a five grand when I
calculate and we're gonna fix a car
again I'm gonna have a two thousand so
everything's fine
so we have two thousand and the balance
is three thousand so if I'm gonna change
this to a grand now this should be a
expenses is still gonna stay 2000 and
now the balance is gonna be negative
thousand because obviously our budget is
one thousand now we have the submit
expense form done now the last one is
gonna be working with these icons with a
edit icon and with a delete icon so let
me go up and let me show you what do I
have so now I would want to select them
somehow because I still want to have
functionality I would want to remove it
or meaning delete it or edit it and that
is it is gonna happen like this again
we're going to remove it from the Dom
we're gonna remove from the list and
then we're gonna place the item here so
if you want to add it and then we can be
able to edit if you would just want to
remove we're just removing which is
deleting from the DOM and from the item
list now this we're gonna set up within
an expense list because as we're added
again we could have technically done
this as a callback function as we're
adding the items here but in our case
were just gonna do a event propagation
where we can just use the event target
this would be another option again it
really doesn't matter how you do it I
just for the sake of the tutorial I just
thought if you do another callback that
might be confusing so let's just skip
this and let's do it with event listener
the only thing we're doing is since we
don't have an access to it normally
since we run the function because the
items we're adding dynamically I would
want to do the click handler
I wouldn't wanna attach the listener for
a parent the parent is gonna be expensed
so anywhere I'm gonna be clicking on an
expense list I would want to get back
what I'm clicking on and the moment I
found out what I'm clicking on then I
would want to do some kind of action
so this is gonna be happening in the
event listeners now again we can do the
simple event target and I don't know why
I'm not actually doing the event why I'm
so brave I'm trying to find the event
target without actually getting the
event so we need the event object first
and then let's do again a console log of
target this is gonna because this
usually clears everything up because the
event and event target sometimes can be
a little bit misleading so we always can
do a console log now obviously this is
not gonna make sense now I'm pressing on
the titles this is not what I want what
I would want is get back the element
that I'm clicking on once we have added
the items and this is like I said we can
do dynamically because there's no way
for us to select those classes just I
mean there is with a callback but not
let's say not to write a function here
we're all gonna be clicking where you're
going to be looking for the edit or
delete item class 500 that expense so
now this is more interesting now we have
the expense to fight expenses $500 and
now we have these two icons this is what
I'm looking for so I'm looking for this
icon edit and in fact I'm actually
looking for the T element the not not
the actual icon I'm not looking for the
icon in fact I would want to get a link
that is a parent of this so we're
actually gonna be using again the parent
element property and the second one is
gonna be I am the trash icon so this is
all good we just need to use the parent
element because the parent loan has the
class so this is the case we're gonna be
going back to a index.html and notice
what I have all right we could have
looked this in objects since we're
obviously adding them but anyway we have
the edit this is the icon that we're
getting back what I need is this edit
icon I want to make sure that the parent
element of the element that I'm clicking
on has this class because then I know
that I'm selecting this icon or delete
icon these are the two icons that I have
so I should be listening to it and
the way we do this we use the parent
element now again we have done this
before so we're not gonna be going crazy
with the console logs anymore we can
just use a parent element console.log
not console.log the property now if you
have confusion about this again I
suggest just console.log out the event
target parent element and everything is
gonna be way more clear than if I spend
another half an hour explaining this so
we're gonna have a target and like I
said we are looking for a parent element
and what is the parent element this is
gonna be a link now the link has what
link has class now the way access the
class we can use the classlist property
now what class list we we can use we can
use contains so what contains contains
offers us to check whether this element
the has the class of whatever we're
running here or not so again this is
really really useful property of class
list and I obviously have contains and
now we're looking for the Edit icon this
is obviously what we want as one option
and the second one is gonna be Delete
icon now here I can do the if so this is
gonna be my first if and then we can
just do the elsif so let me just grab
copy and paste this and here let's say
else and if now I'm not gonna be looking
for edit icon this is where I'm gonna be
looking for a delete icon now what do
you think we need over here we need some
function because obviously for now we're
just always saying as well if it is or
if it's not I mean we can write
something here that might be fun but we
need a function now what is the function
well we can get the function from the
method of our class instance right so we
can do UI then let's write what method
we're gonna be creating edit and we're
gonna write expense expense now this
method again I created obviously before
and this expense is gonna take one
parameter and that parameter is gonna be
the parent element so basically a link
so here we're gonna do the same thing so
if we're looking for the element that
has the class
I also would want to select the same
element so I'm just gonna use an event
target and parent element it so I'm
basically getting back tooling now this
would be the other Hill expense and the
same is gonna be for to delete expense
now here we're just gonna use a
different name so delete expense and
again the same thing it accepts the
parameter of event target parent element
so some kind of object or my apology is
some kind of element now obviously since
we're working with Dom we're all gonna
be getting back an object but now we
will gonna go up again to a class so
total expense was our last one then I
don't know either underneath or above it
doesn't really matter whatever it makes
sense to you it's sometimes it's hard to
for me to decide for the tutorial where
to place everything but yeah we just
need to create these methods and we're
done now these methods might be a little
bit lengthy but we're gonna be fine
added expense the name of the method
expense and expensive first of all I
need to learn how to properly write
everything and here this is the element
so this is the element that I'm getting
back now so this is a parameter and here
this is an argument there I'm expecting
the element here I'm passing the element
now the second one is going to be delete
expense where I'm gonna do the same
thing we're just gonna write delete
expense and again we're gonna pass the
element so some kind of down Dom element
that we're getting back and first you
know what we're just gonna write the
first edit I had it expense this might
be a little bit longer and then we'll
have a delete expense so we're almost
there I mean we all we just have pretty
much two methods that we need to work on
this is gonna be low but maybe probably
comp complicated than before but the
lead expense now
comments done the methods done great so
let's work on it
remember again we had that idea correct
remember we passed this Eddie so we're
gonna make use of this ID how do we
access this
attribute well we need to use data set
so we will use a data set and we're
going to access this by using data set
dot ID now this is important because
again this is gonna help us tremendously
because otherwise then we really need to
do a lot of a Dom traversing so we need
to have access to this ID now how do I
have access to this ID first I'm gonna
create a very long and I said this is
gonna be equal to ID then what I'm gonna
be getting back is gonna be string again
so again we're gonna use parse int so
parse integer now what I would need I
would need element now element has what
it has the data ID attribute now I could
use a data set like I said properly now
for the data set only thing that matters
is what name it is since this is data ID
I'm using data dot ID because I couldn't
write like this this is not gonna make
sense I need to write it as a object
property so I'm getting back the ID then
I'm gonna work with a parent and I'm
gonna remove this parent from the list
again why am I getting the parent
because look at the expense list I have
the expense list and I need to go up the
Dom traversed at home all the way up to
the expense list and make sure that it
deletes whatever parent element of my
icon now it's not gonna be direct parent
element because notice again the icons
are sitting within a div then this div
is sitting within something so we need
to kind of hop up to the Dom get the
proper parent element and just delete it
and trust me whenever you're working
this is a lot of pretty much console
logging you just okay parent element
okay what is the point
okay next parent old okay now I got to
the point where I need okay let's just
get this sucker out of this expense list
so let's go up and again we'll just
going to be doing very simple we're
gonna say let's parent and now we just
need to hop few steps up so the first
one is going to be
element I'm getting back the element
then I'm getting back the parent element
and again if this is confusing just
console.log it it's gonna make way more
sense so again another parent element
another hop above and then another one
so basically we hopped three times so
I'm gonna have a element whatever
element we got back but remember already
within this element we did the parent
element so technically we have four hops
we're doing first here with the parent
element property and then we're doing
three more so we have element one more
two more add three more so here we're
selecting the parent parent which is
actually this whole item and then after
that we would want this expense list so
the list that's holding all the items we
just want to remove it now we know that
we can remove it by first of all first
probably it's gonna make sense if we're
gonna having a from Dom the comment this
expense list this is the grandfather of
all these elements you can call it like
this now how does a stitch thing doesn't
exist but let's just call it grandfather
and we just want to remove the parent so
whatever parent we're getting back we
will just want to remove from the
expense list then the second one is way
more interesting this is again using the
filter where we would want to remove
from the parade that we had remember we
even though we remove it from Dom we
still have this in the array because
remember we place the item whenever we
had the expenses so remember we had the
item now I also would want to filter
this out and I would want to filter out
for two reasons first I would want to
filter out so i get the value so I can
place whatever I have within the item
let's say the value and the amount so I
can add it and the second one is I would
want to return the array without that
item so first things first let's get the
value my friends so we have the remove
from the list and we have completed
already remove remove from the list
remove from the list
and I'm sorry sometimes it's hard to
talk and type so sometimes I'm gonna
talk I'm just gonna stop and type so let
expenses expense this item list again
this is the array that holds all our
values now we can use the filter to find
and what we would want to find I would
want to find the item so have a function
the item that has the ID D has the ID of
this ID so whatever item in our array
that has this ID we would want to return
it and we would want to turn it to this
specific variable so here we're gonna
have item but remember the filter is
gonna return the new array so again
we're gonna have to select a 0 parent
not 0 parent sorry I've been talking
about parents too much 0 item so 0 index
item not not just this is not gonna
return the variable this is gonna return
and you are a so callback function now
within the callback question we're
iterating through the whole array and
I'm gonna say like this if the item that
I'm iterating through so that that exact
item in my array if this item ID matches
whatever ID I'm getting back from my
element dataset then I'm solid and I
just wanna return this if not then I
just move on and in the perfect world if
everything is correct since the all the
IDS are unique this should return only
about there should be no other value so
first of all gonna get expense now the
second one is we would want to work with
a rest of the list correct because we
have a one that is the item and the
second again we need we need to remove
this item from the list at least
temporarily because what is the point of
editing if it was going to be adding a
new value so how do we do this we're
gonna say remove from the way I'm saying
list is done sorry
list no relation and again we're doing
filtering now what is the filter in this
time
now I'm gonna set a variable so I'm
gonna say let and this is gonna stand
for a temporary list so temp list I can
name this whatever so this item list
again selecting the same array again
using the same filter now this time I
don't want to return this one item I
don't care about that I already got that
I'm fine
I would need the rest of the list and
then I'm gonna use this template and I'm
gonna assign this to a my list right now
so filter again callback function within
a call varnish on the parameter the
parameter I refers to every item in the
list and here we're gonna say return and
I only want to return what I wanna
return the item item that does not have
the same ID so rest of the items that
does not have the ID so that ID can stay
in original list but in the temporary
list we're just gonna remove all the
items that don't have that ID and now
it's very simple we're just gonna say
you know what
since we have this mo doesn't say this
item list
so whatever original list we have we'll
just reassign it and was gonna say temp
list BAM here we go so now this item
does not exist anymore at least in a
list right now now once we're gonna
again press an expense once we have
added everything is gonna be fine
however right now we don't want it and
also what we want is we want to show the
balance because remember that every time
we're changing something in a list we
would want to run the show the balance
otherwise we're gonna be updating
something and this is not gonna show up
over here so we're gonna run the ad of
balance I'm sorry show the balance that
we had before and now we have the item
list and this would be the template now
the last thing I just want to add the
values here because remember as I'm
editing I would want them to show up
over here so again we can do this in the
bottom we can do this after we have
selected the item doesn't really matter
here we're gonna say show value and
remember what I was saying with the
filter the filter is gonna return the
array so if I wouldn't access this item
because I know this is an object now
obviously because I place it as an
so I'm getting back in the lab but it is
an object as a zero index in the array
so now I'm going to set this expense
input now this is I'm getting back from
these selections or the property's value
and we're gonna do expense since this is
what I'm getting back zero so zero index
value and you're gonna say tile and
again we can do a bunch of console logs
here alone but just to skip a little bit
ahead let's just do this without console
logs and if you have any issues again
you can just count along and you'll see
what I'm talking about so we'll have a
expense and now instead of title I would
want to select the amount so this is all
that's happening so we have the expense
which is an array which is gonna hold
one object and again you can console.log
it and you'll see and what I'm saying is
true and then we're gonna be getting
back the titles over here so let's least
test it out so everything is working so
let's do a budget of five grand let's
calculate fix the car for a thirty three
thousand time adding expense
sure enough we have three hundred so
this is gonna be forty seven hundred now
if I'm gonna click Edit what's gonna
happen notice first I'm getting the
values back this is the last thing that
we did expense zero dot title great so
we have these values now also we removed
from the expenses and now the balance is
back to the five thousand so again this
was the reason for the show of balance
that we were on and if I'm gonna change
this expense to let's say eight hundred
boom now I have to fix the car is gonna
be eight hundred and everything is
calculated correctly now the last thing
is the delete expense so newly it
explains however the good news is a lot
of this is exactly the same so we can do
a first of all that I'm moving the
parent so this is gonna be exactly the
same we just want to remove from the Dom
so let's just copy and paste it then I
don't know why I've removed from
down ties I guess I messed it up again
with my comments which is pretty typical
remove from the list this is not from
the list we're moving from the list and
again we're gonna do the same thing
we're just grabbing the items whatever
we have removed from the list temp list
ID again temp list and reassigning and
showing the balance that's it so the a
the deletion is actually very simple
just fix it in like what 30 seconds
without me
well imagine without me talking then
that's what i'm talking with me yapping
this could be another three hours yeah
so I think everything works correctly
and I want to feel brave and I want to
actually open up in the browser and I'm
probably gonna regret this because
there's gonna be mistake and you're
gonna be laughing like your heads off
but anyway yeah what's this they're out
so we have the budget budget is great I
mean it's great if you're probably
positive not negative but anyway 5,000
great awesome five grand you know what
let's do ten ten is even better let's
add zero well no way buddy okay
expenses let's start with the zero let's
say there's no expenses well there's not
possible okay
fixing the car but you know what
mechanic actually paid me no way you
didn't pay you let's do maybe negative
budget because I forgot this is a
negative budget again yep no can do
awesome great everything is working fine
we probably you know what we should you
know now we're gonna leave we could
technically add input where it's zero
right now if we add the incorrect value
but I don't think it makes sense so we
have fixed car let's just leave it so
let what the user actually fix it if
it's his mistake then you should fix it
no I have fix a car removed from budget
blah blah blah budget nine nine nine
seven nine expense value is 21 let's add
another one let's do the same of this is
a buying of the milk by them buying or
buy the milk by the milk I'm gonna want
three hundred
mm let's make some fun milk expenses
budget balance BAM six nine seven nine
and yeah so we have expense value what
we can do we can delete if we want to
delete
goes back to 21 if we would want to edit
again it removes temporarily and now
let's do fixing the car of twenty-one
thousand and sure enough poor sucker is
in the death not that death depth yeah
so this would be it for the project guys
I hope you enjoyed it and I hope you I
hope to you next project